it's hard to remember a liberal Democrat
conference this buoyant this confidence
this purposeful tens of thousands of new
members seven new MPs who have defected
from rival parties and a new young
leader on a mission we must stop breaks
it we are crystal clear
a Liberal Democrat majority government
will revoke article 50 on day one
because there is no breaks it that will
be good for our country isn't it
anti-democratic to cancel a referendum
result and cancel brexit some say so
even a few liberal democrats but brexit
has put the UK in uncharted political
waters norms are being discarded left
right and center by parties here and
choice Winston has decided that absolute
clarity is a vote winner there is no
limit to my ambition for our party and
our country and today I am standing here
as your candidate for Prime Minister
Britain's headed for an election before
the end of the year
so MP Sam Jima who's just joined the
party from the Conservatives says you
can't call a policy anti-democratic when
it's about to be put to the people it's
not extreme if the country votes for a
liberal democratic government and that
is their manifesto and that is not
extreme at all and is no more extreme
than what we we potentially have today
which is a minority Conservative
government trying to implement a No Deal
that nobody voted for and that's a view
endorsed by members I don't think
they've a friend was a democratic
exercise myself I think was an exercise
in party politics and a mistake revoking
article 50 should they get the mandate
through a general election absolutely
because the mandate would be there
the consequences of the lib dems last
experience of power was near extinction
when the country next voted but that was
when they controversially shared
government as a junior partner to David
Cameron's Conservatives can the Liberal
Democrats win the election expected in
November or December
well probably not they are still third
in the polls behinds the Conservatives
and labor but recent years have shown us
that the polls are often fallible
anything can happen
Joe Swinson has said she won't go into
coalition with either Boris Johnson or
Labour leader Jeremy Corbyn she's in
this to win war each Allen's fantasy
reformer